Islam
is raising funds to establish a masjid
and community center in Norway and they
urgently need your support. This
donation will be a saddak for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation,
you will in reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you can. Look
how Allah works in mysterious ways. We
just came off this train and there was
two sisters. One is a new Muslim. The
other one is half Pakistani, half
English. We come off the train and Jabby
noticed them. I think they saw my videos
Tik Tok. They said, "I think they've
clocked you." We go and they're like,
they come to me and go, "Are you that
guy on TikTok?" I was like, "Yeah." I
was like, "Oh my gosh." And we watch
your videos, etc. They are right behind
us. We're going to go to them. Subhan
Allah. Guys, you can't make this up.
She's just accepted Islam and they both
don't know how to pray salah. Inshallah.
Okay. Uh, I'm going to give this to you.
You can hold this. So, yeah, we just
came off the same train and I think you
noticed myself.
>> Yeah, I did. Okay. So, she came to me
and she was like, "Are you that guy on
social media?" And I said, "Yeah." She
goes, "This sister here, what's your
name?"
>> Grace.
>> Grace. And
>> Zora.
>> Zora. So, Grace and Zora. Grace has
accepted Islam when
>> when
two three months ago.
>> Two, three months ago. Subhan Allah.
Okay. So, we don't believe in
coincidences. It's as if Allah sent us
for you guys specifically. I've got a
gift for you guys. In I'm just going to
open it cuz the mat is the suitcase is
full of inshallah. So this will
inshallah I just open it for you.
So this is the reason we came here by
the way. Yeah. Okay. So as you can see
it's actually uh so this is a guided
prayer map. It will teach you how to
pray. That's for you. And there's one
for you. I'll show you what it looks
like. I'll just show you what it looks
like in. Yeah.
>> So subhan Allah guys. It's absolutely
crazy. It just Subhan Allah. And this is
what it looks like. I'll show you
inshallah. So do you know how to do
wudoo?
>> Oh yeah.
>> You do you do know how to do this? Yeah.
So good. You okay? This will show you
how to do that. And the mat looks a bit
like this.
>> Oh, that's so
>> Yeah. So, so, so it's it's it's simple
me too. It's not the one that talks back
to you, but it teaches you how to pray
salah instantly. Inshallah. Yeah. So, I
believe Allah brought us all the way
from London for one of the reasons.
Subhan Allah. May Allah bless you.
Inshallah. So, yeah. Um, you can learn
that. And also, if you want to learn
like on on face to face or Zoom, we have
a sisters team. So if you go to our app,
we have an app called Salah Pro.
>> I'll show you inshallah. So you could
book an instructor. So that's our app.
>> Mhm.
>> You can go on it and you can, it's got
like salah times, you know, if you want
to find the kibla
>> to pray, etc. If you go to this tab,
book an instructor, salah instructor.
Just go to female. So one of our sisters
teams can teach you over Zoom. So her
name is Sister Fedria. She's Italian
revert. Yeah. Oh, really?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So it's And by the way, it's
for free. All of our service are free in
Yes. Can I ask um Sister Grace, what
made you come to Islam?
>> Um
traditional
>> was it was it just
>> to to be honest with you like obviously
I saw like a lot of people like how
peaceful and stuff it was and I always
knew there was a god but I never really
knew who. Obviously I did research and
stuff like that. I did I researched
Islam
>> and then it just it just clicked with
me. Um but I was telling Zora um I think
what was it like 3 days before I took my
shahada I had a dream I had a dream that
I said my shahada I didn't know what
shahada was I spoke to Zora
>> so in your shocking you didn't know what
the shahada was before
>> you see a dream
>> in your dream you
>> in my dream I read
>> and you've never heard shahada before
>> I've never heard it before but I said it
so perfectly I woke up I asked her what
it meant and obviously she was like yeah
that's your shahada
>> so in the dream you say it then you ask
her what it is that
That is that is wow. Subhan Allah. And
then from there, how did you accept
Islam? Did you do it with her or did you
go to the mosque?
>> Uh well, we went to the mosque like was
it how long after was it?
>> No, literally the same day. So you went
and I talked to one of my teachers teach
me when I used to go mosque when I was
younger.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh I said my friend wants to learn
more about Islam. She'll ask you
questions and everything.
>> And then she just took a shad off at the
end of the day.
>> That is I'll be honest with you. I
haven't I've heard a lot of shahada
stories but I've never heard that in a
dream.
>> Look how Allah Allah works in miracles.
Not only that, the fact that Subhan
Allah like Allah got us to come on this
trip.
>> I know.
>> And then we come off there and you see
us and you're like, "Okay, are you that
guy?" And then we've got a whole box of
mats that we're bringing to Bradford to
cuz we supply mosques, da tables, and
prisons. So, new Muslims. And then look,
it's as if Allah brought us here. I'll
hand deliver this to you guys. Subhan
Allah. It's here. May Allah bless you
in. And yourself, you you you're born
from Muslim family.
>> Yeah. So, so that's funny.
>> Okay, good. So, you've always been a
Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And but you haven't you don't know
how to pray salah?
>> I do, but I don't at the same time. Do
you know like you know like for
different it's different things. Do you
know what I mean?
>> Okay. Good.
>> So, obviously I didn't really know
properly.
>> Um but I don't know. I've just been on
and off. Like this time last year, I was
wearing hijab. I was reading all my
namas. You know what I mean? I was
really good this time last year. And
like now obviously I don't wear hijab. I
don't do these things. It's my own
journey. Do you know what I'm saying?
>> Exactly. Sister, let me tell you
something. I have my ups and downs. Yes.
I'm I'm in the da. Yeah. I'm seen as an
Islamic figure. We all have our ups and
downs. So, it's just a journey.
Alhamdulillah. And best of im
companions, they had the ups and downs.
The im it's a part of faith to believe.
You have your good days and you have a
bad days. But you know what's the
important thing that at least you're
trying and you're trying your best to
try and that's what matters. So, this
map will help you pray. It's got
everything you need to know. The app, if
you download, it's called Salah Pro. So
if you just type this in,
>> you can download it for free in your nam
times. If you want someone to help you
learn, you can do that as well.
>> Especially with Ramadan coming up as
well. I want to I want to start reading
the cuz if I start reading nams as well,
I can help her properly and everything.
You know what I mean?
>> You can help each other. And we've got a
new feature on the app. You can we're
trying to get it developed. You nudge
each other. So like when it's salah time
Yeah. you nudge each other. Hey time.
>> In. Do you have any questions? Anything
that you wanted to know about Islam or
any even yourself? anything that I
couldn't answer
anything that's in your mind like I
didn't notice anything if there is if
there is nothing it's fine nothing's
coming no problem that's fine in
yourself
>> no
>> perfect inshallah bro it's just there
you can't make this up okay we don't
believe in coincidences it's the of
Allah and sometimes Allah subhanaa tala
looks at the hearts and god knows what
kind of sincere hearts that you had that
Allah brought us here specifically for
you guys to give these mats and it's an
honor and pleasure my sisters may Allah
bless you guys it was really nice
meeting you guys make use of Inshallah.
And I want to thank our donors cuz we're
a charity by the way. So the reason we
give this out for free, all of our
service are for free is because people
donate.
>> And these mats just came from China. So
we ordered 50,000 in seven different
languages. So subhan Allah. I just want
to thank the donors. And this is a real
life example guys where you come off a
train and not in a million they would
have if they told me what do you think
is going to happen in less. I said but
I'm going to get off the train and go
catch my other train. No. Allah had a
plan which is what you're going to come
off a train see two sisters. One's a new
Muslim, one's a born Muslim and subhan
Allah give them mats. I would not in my
wildest dreams believe that would have
happened but Allah works in mysterious
ways. Please keep them in your dua
sister Grace in Zorra.
>> May Allah bless and preserve them
inshallah. Till next time.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation, you will in
be reaping the reward. Click the link
and donate what you